it's it's like if you lived in a world
where no one worked out how quickly
could you go to the gym before your body
made you exceptional like it wouldn't
take very long and that's the world that
we live in with regards to charisma is
nobody's working on it so all you have
to do is is this very small amount
before people are going to start to
notice that you're in an elite tier
charlie hooper in the building how are
you doing man excellent in my own
building on the other side of the ocean
but happy to be here nonetheless yeah
i'm man me too me too what does a
morning what does a charlie hooper
morning routine look like
so there's no routine i wake up around
11 i let my dog outside
sometimes he's gone inside so i try to
do that for him uh and then i have some
calls related to charisma on command
exercise around 1 32 p.m sauna i have
like a
barrel sauna in the backyard which is
[ __ ] awesome best best
uh four-figure purchase i've ever made
in my life i love that thing
and then in the evening i'll play league
of legends and scream at the computer
with my friends
the most toxic it is the most toxic
hobby and that's the definitely the one
thing i don't recommend for my schedule
for anyone else do not pick up league of
legends if you've avoided it thus far
why
so
i
am medium competitive in normal life but
league of legends brings out my most
vicious cruel
whiny complainy it's your fault side
this is [ __ ] [ __ ] i truly believe
that there is something in the game and
of course something inside of me but
there is something in the structure of
the game where one person can just
destroy and melt down
15 to 30 minutes of hard work and me
feeling like i'm better than the person
i'm playing against and i just [ __ ]
lose my mind every time i play but it's
it's the worst addiction that i have uh
but i
like every addiction i just
derive some sense of satisfaction from
it so i don't stop yeah yeah yeah i've
just got back from doing a walk this is
my equivalent of
getting mad at league of legends things
i just got back from a walk and there is
a running club that does a run on my my
walk route and
sometimes the people that are running
they just get in my way so that's like
my equivalent that i'm there on my walk
i'm moving slower than them but
sometimes dude i saw a woman if you ever
this is definitely an la thing
people that have a special sort of belt
that they attach a dog lead to so that
the dog can run with the person
and i'm
i'm watching this thing and the dog's
sniffing along a wall looking for
somewhere to do a wii i'm thinking if
you
if you don't keep your eye on that dog
you're going to end up being yanked like
this to one side this big [ __ ]
alsatian thing i'm like you're
annihilated that's you your dog's going
to be flat on its side and you're going
to fall over on this icy road yeah in la
the dogs are like 8 to 10 pounds max but
it's it's the same sort of thing that we
have out here which is we often have
these women who push their dogs in
strollers uh and to
a dog it's it's this white fluffy little
thing i swear to god and they
are the
worst behaved dogs you've ever seen they
scream and bark at everybody that's
that's what a lot of la's like very
poorly trained animals that are just
peeing and pooping in the wrong places
and barking at you like you on league of
legends
yes yes exactly
exactly like me in league of legends so
yeah i should be less judgmental of
those poor dogs because we have a lot in
common yeah so you've been coaching
people on how to be more charismatic and
better communicators for a very very
long time and that's the
fundamentals of your channel as well
charisma on command which is [ __ ]
dope and congratulations on creating
something which is
managed to be both popular and actually
add value which i think is
a difficult uh a very difficult sort of
balance to strike
how do you after all of this time
thinking about how do you break down
charisma into its component parts like
how do you see it now after all of this
time thinking about it
well there's a lot of different
frameworks that i've used over the years
um
one of them is is that there's not
simply one style of christmas i guess
i'll even step back generally i think of
charisma as the ability to influence
other people and i take out of that
things that obviously influence other
people like beauty and talent because
while you know that there's other
channels for that if you want to learn
how to be super hot and sexy you can be
very influential
yeah exactly
he's got everything you need for your
beauty tips
and if you know elon musk he i was just
listening to him on lex friedman he's
stuttering you know stumbling over what
he says very often
takes a long time which isn't
necessarily bad in itself to communicate
a point but you don't want to emulate
his speaking style what you might want
to emulate is perhaps his work ethic and
his first principles thinking so i i
take all of that stuff out of the realm
of influence and what you're left with
is basically personality and
character-driven influence and there's
different types of it
one type you could think of like a conor
mcgregor type person super high
conviction a steve jobs who gets other
people to want to be near them around
them participate in their things because
we love people
that seem like they can know the future
like we want to be around people that
have deep deep beliefs in what they're
doing and why they're doing it because
so many of us lack that in ourselves so
you've got the high conviction types
you've got authentic types you're joe
rogans who you implicitly trust because
they say things that put themselves at
social disadvantage sometimes they'll
say the unpopular opinion or say hey i
don't agree with this mainstream take on
things and that slowly over time builds
a deep sense of trust in those who have
spent the most time around them you've
got your comedians your kevin harts all
those type of people who are just funny
and they make you smile and laugh
anytime you're around them energetic
types like will smith who they come into
the talk show and they're big and loud
and whenever you're around them you just
you want to participate in the vibe that
they're bringing and then lastly you
have your empathetic types like oprah
winfrey who will sit down lookie in the
eye and ask you you know you know what
would your mother say about that and
bring a tear to your eye and make you
cry so there's not necessarily one style
to do but those are the generally the
five types that i see most commonly in
the breakdowns that we do and then it's
just a matter of
picking and choosing the things that
feel
closest to where you are while
you know being willing to change but not
losing the thing about you that that you
might want to keep and that that's often
a question we get how do you be
charismatic while retaining the essence
of who you are
is there a tension there between those
i think so yeah for sure and and when
you're starting to learn i think one of
the biggest
uh the biggest obstacles to people's
changing anything in their life is that
this feels like who they are and what i
often tell them is that
the personality that you're showcasing
today is not intrinsic to who you are
it's not how you were born it is often
the traumas and successes of 13 year old
you have shaped the way that you are and
sometimes you have that guy who is the
stud at age 13 and for the rest of his
life he just acts like a little prince
and you can have this
45 years old but still crushing it
because he was the hottest kid in school
at 13. yes exactly and then you have you
know you have the flip side of that
which was more me was uh much more
reverb
reserved quiet didn't feel that i had
the right to take up any space and that
needs to be
unlearned and the thing that gets in the
way is thinking oh no this is me i am
just
introverted shy and and any movement
away from this would be a self betrayal
so that's oftentimes the first obstacle
that we have to overcome when anyone is
learning is there is a you in there we
just want to be the best version of
yourself not necessarily who you were
conditioned to be in middle school
yeah that self betrayal is an
interesting way to frame it there's
something uh like sacred
about the the natural way that you have
got yourself to this point but
i don't know maybe it's my exposure to
the personal development world that
most of that feels like bollocks to me
most of that just feels like you
rationalizing
random chance as opposed to
intentional effort
look you've had a ton of influences on
your charisma and your extroversion and
your introversion and your speech
patterns and so on and so forth the fact
that you didn't get to choose them
doesn't make them any more a part of you
than the ones that you did get to choose
absolutely yeah yeah no that's we we
deal with this question often times at
the beginning and i'll say some version
of what you just said which is you
didn't choose these influences on you
yet you treat them as if you could not
possibly change them without cutting off
one of your own arms and that i think
the reason that this is such a sticky
belief is because it's self-serving in
some ways it's easier to get
crappy social results crappy
professional results than it is to take
on the effort of oh no this is my
responsibility i can change it without
being immoral or unethical but it might
be challenging and it might make me do
things that scare me and require a lot
of courage therefore my brain is going
to do me the favor of just saying oh no
that would be that wouldn't be me that's
a self-betrayal i don't even have to
worry about that and i can just complain
instead about some of the results that
i'm getting so
that that can be a trap early on for a
lot of people but i think once people
get into our channel hopefully
the philosophy of how to evolve is
implicit in a lot of what we teach and
it's not
destroy everything about you who you
were it is it is improved things try
these different patterns and these
different habits on like a style of
clothing it doesn't have to become who
you are but these might get you better
results in your social endeavors
who were your main influences when you
were learning this stuff charisma and
communication and confidence and stuff
yeah it was so there were sometimes guys
you'll never know or the friends that
were in my friend group that would
literally just repeat jokes that i said
quietly and get a big laugh
it drove me nuts there's one guy austin
who was just like a hurricane of
charisma uh and he was he was a friend
of a friend whenever i hung around him i
felt special whenever he was nice to me
literally he would repeat things that i
said and the group would follow him i'd
be like hey guys is it time to go out to
get lunch no response five minutes later
yo i'm feeling pretty hungry yeah
so that that type of thing everybody uh
all the people around me who are getting
different results actually had a much
larger influence on me than any
celebrity or any talk show host or
anything like that
what about
books books uh yeah when i was starting
a lot of it was
books that
told me that i could change so tony
robbins was a big influence early on i'm
trying to think what the other ones were
six pillars of self-esteem by nathaniel
brandon was huge the idea that
self-esteem we we have this idea i think
increasingly and he talks about it
probably when he wrote in the 70s or 80s
that self-esteem is one's birth right
that you ought to just feel
really good about yourself because you
exist and he takes a very different
approach which is
self-esteem is your reputation with
yourself and if you're the type of
person who lies all the time doesn't
keep your word doesn't go to the gym
when you set your new year's resolution
your reputation with yourself is going
to be a lousy one that of somebody who
is unreliable
lies all these sorts of things and by
changing your behavior you can change
the way that you perceive yourself and
that has a profound effect on how you
present yourself to other people and
then how they perceive you so that book
was
instrumental for giving me
not just platitudes about self-esteem
like you deserve it
you can do it affirmative type things
but here's what you need to do in your
life and in fact he has these sentence
completions exercises that'll be like
if i was five percent more integris
today i would and you fill these things
out and i would often write i wouldn't
have fibbed about that thing that i lied
about in conversation i probably would
have talked to that girl that i had a
crush on and not pretended to you know
not have noticed her at all and so you
write these out and over time they weigh
on you and you start to do the things
that would make you have more integrity
and then you feel better about yourself
and it's got this whole positive
feedback look so i love love love uh six
pillars of self-esteem that's the naval
thing right confidence isn't given it's
earned and it makes sense why wouldn't
it be why wouldn't it be the sort of
thing that you need to prove to yourself
it's a reputation that you have with
yourself and you're always keeping score
even if you don't think you are
yes yes and i'm sure i'm sure we'll talk
about it
the
where where i came from i think where a
lot of people come from is
you are your patterns right that's
that's what we learned you are who you
were and 13 years old in middle school
and the big shift was here is you can
become your habits right you can shift
these habits you can change the way that
you feel about yourself
and i'd say recently i've
gone back a little bit and recovered the
sense that they're
i thought that i wasn't an introvert
throughout my 20s because i built these
extroverted habits and i've recently
realized that no i definitely still have
this introverted streak in me that
doesn't seem to go away
despite any sort of habituation and so i
do think that there is
an essence to our personality but we
probably overestimate what that is when
we're in our young 20s and haven't done
any sort of self-development work and
it's only now that i'm in my 30s that i
can be like
this was me this is what got laid on top
of me i want to take out what got laid
on top of me choose other things but
also respect
that there are these parts of me that do
not that seem so resistant to change
that i'm just gonna you know embrace
them and love them and accept them even
if they're not ideal for social
scenarios like i'm an introvert and you
know i'm pissed at league of legends
which probably probably isn't core to my
behavior i'm just joking about that one
how do you define uh introvert and
extrovert
i i think the way that i've heard most
commonly defined is not well here's the
trick is some people think if i like
social situations therefore i'm an
extrovert if i don't like them and i'm
an introvert and i think a trap there is
that you can not like social situations
because you don't know how to manage
them and therefore any sort of social
situation that you're in is going to
suck and you can compare it to like do
you like basketball or don't you well
you would like it if you were a dominant
center that was scoring all the time and
you'd probably hate it if you got
blocked every single time so it's tough
to evaluate if you like social
situations or not before you have the
skill talent personality to succeed and
enjoy them at the highest level so what
i saw is that at first i was like no i'm
an introvert
then i learned how to succeed in social
situations and i was elated had a great
time in bars clubs you know networking
events all those sorts of things
but in reflecting on it i still see that
those situations drained me even at the
end and i really often times enjoy
staying home reading a book being left
alone and i get some of my
best thinking
and uh most
some of my happiest moments are alone
and i think i think there's something
very introverted about that when i could
be out on a friday night and i am just
so
happy to not be not because i couldn't
do the things that i might want to do on
that friday night socially but because i
just love being alone so that's that's
why i say that i'm an introvert yeah the
best definition that iv or the most
useful definition that i've heard for it
is
where do you get your energy from do you
get your energy from being on your own
or do you get your energy from being
around other people if you're around
other people are loads do you need to
think [ __ ] me all right you got to spend
a couple of evenings in the house on my
own or if you do that do you start
climbing the walls and needing to go out
there's another
relating to
the this tension between inner essence
and sort of truth and then ability to
make yourself and becoming being and
stuff like that um i had robert plowman
the
fourth most cited psychologist of the
20th century on the show so he's a
gene's behavioral geneticist guy and he
said our nature does not predetermine
but it does predispose
that was how he put it across for
instance you could have the genes and
the predisposition to be an alcoholic
but if you're born on an island that
doesn't have any alcohol it's not going
to happen
yeah um so there is this there's always
this tension right there's always this
tension between your conditioning and
your um predisposition
yeah and of course the environment which
is what you just described there which
is
maybe you're predisposed to be an
introvert but you get this early
positive feedback in social situations
that's going to be very different for
for how you wind up in life so my goal
was to know that i could that i could
succeed in social situations and then to
make that free choice knowing i could go
out and have it be really fun and not
terrifying or i could stay in and have
it be whatever that's going to be now i
want to make the choice and i find
myself increasingly making the choice to
stay in not out of fear which is what it
was for the first i don't know 18 20
years of my life but out of a genuine
free decision where i i could find
enjoyment in either scenario i think
derek from more plates more dates says
the same thing he has the same approach
like he was terrified of approaching
girls and was always
i think he's he he felt a little bit
when he's talking about it kind of like
having a gun to his head in a
relationship because he was always
terrified the relationship would end
because he had nothing in the locker to
be able to get a new one if it did which
put him in a needy state and anyone
that's read mark manson's models knows
that's not a very powerful position to
be and being needy is going to turn the
other party off especially as a guy
so i think that was his solution as well
look i want to give myself more
sovereignty and the more degrees of
freedom that i have access to even if i
choose to not use the extra version or
they're going out or any of that the
more that i can do the more comfortable
that i'm going to feel in myself
yeah 100 you know i'm curious if you had
this because i know you do the nightclub
stuff and have been in promotion for a
while when i first moved to california
i'd been so throughout my 20s i had
trained myself you know on friday and
saturday nights you go out you have to
have a good time i had actually
instilled in myself a sense of social
fomo where if i wasn't
participating in the event i felt a
tremendous amount of anxiety and i
didn't realize it until my first weekend
in california when i didn't have any
friends in the area it was a friday
night
and by all accounts i should have just
moved my stuff in unpacked but i have to
go i have to find the bar i gotta be on
yelp i gotta go for whatever i'm gonna
be by myself that's what i have to do
and i recognized that
while it was a fantastic journey and i
learned a lot in becoming more outgoing
and charismatic and confident that i had
created some new neuroses and some new
anxieties around
needing to do that instead of being able
to do that so that's sort of what i've
been unwinding in the last couple of
years is truly trying to have the choice
because i recognize in my 20s i felt
like i had a choice but really i just
went to the flip side of the coin and
demanded that of myself constantly yeah
[ __ ] well so i never had that with
partying and that's the difference
between being the party and running the
party i i went out and partied but we
had a
kind of like an unwritten rule that you
just didn't get [ __ ] at your own event
like you can go and cause complete havoc
at
six nights a week
just on a saturday when our money's on
the line and you've got to cash the till
at the end of the night and if there's
any problems with the police or the
council or the management you need to
deal with it just you know hang fire and
there'll be an after party and you can
sniff your head off until 2 pm on a
sunday or whatever and it's it's sweet
um but you're it's so interesting the
how would you say the malignant side
effects
that you create by doing a thing
downstream what that like the after
ripples that that causes so you wanted
to create
um an ability to go out and be
extroverted and be charismatic that
meant that you had to go out frequently
that meant that you had to fall in love
you had to actually generate a degree of
love for going out or else the willpower
to do it would have been completely
unbelievable and then after a while you
realize oh hang on i i'm like being
dragged along by the creature that i
created here so the thing that happened
with me was with regards to business i
ran a business i wanted the business to
be successful i needed to start to
generate that engine and to start to get
that moving and then i couldn't slow the
momentum down when i wanted to take time
away from work i had fomo and fear
around delegating responsibility around
starting to move myself out and giving
other people different tasks that they
could do so that my workload would be
reduced uh and that's still now man
that's one of the main
uh existential challenges that i have
look like work less work less be less
neurotic about the things that you need
to do so there's
people needs that during those years
like 18 to 25 like be careful of the
things that you dedicate yourself to
because those are the things that you're
going to try and deprogram when you're
you got to d program later that's funny
i think that it is
almost a natural law that the advantages
of one phase of your life will be the
obstacles in the subsequent one and and
the thing that you're trying to unwind
delegating
you had to learn when you were starting
your business that you couldn't delegate
in fact you probably would have loved to
have delegate early on but you needed to
develop the skill of saying i can't
trust anybody to do this it's nobody's
going to come help me i got to do it
myself so you build that muscle and it's
absolutely necessary until you get to a
point in which you have to go hey that
thing that got you here is
the obstacle to getting to whatever
comes after this and so i think that
that is true in any sort of personal
development and all that i've come up
with is when it's time you're going to
have to let go and it's going to be a
[ __ ] it's going to be
very uncomfortable to unwind what you've
done before and seemingly go backwards
but you're not it's like a spiral you
know
you couldn't delegate down here and then
you're coming back around and now
delegating is a good thing yeah there's
two uh
two things that come to mind one i
watched a video today that was really
well done about um the problem with the
personal development world just one of
those youtube videos but the guy had a
really good point he had a problem with
hustle culture because he said that it
gets people to focus on working harder
as opposed to working more effectively
so um speed over direction and this is
the equivalent there that what got you
here the amount of hard work and graft
and grind and knows against the
grindstone in late nights you know if
you are he uses the example of writing a
fitness blog and just grinding it out
three articles a day for five years when
you don't realize that actually taking a
step back and thinking well should i be
doing youtube should i spend a little
bit time on there or maybe if i actually
didn't do a blog but i kind of did some
live streams or i did whatever
strategies that would that would be one
of the things that would change and um
yet to
it's a real interesting one man like the
challenges that people have around these
things as they grow up it's um
yeah i wanted to ask
i'm curious if this is just my circle
i've noticed that the people around me
at least that seem to struggle are some
of the hustle culture people and the
people that have now that i'm 34 and you
know a lot of us started we were 23 it's
been 10 years the people that have made
businesses that have worked they have
worked hard but they've never been grind
set hustle most of them are not grind
set hustle culture type people and i'm
curious if that's just a an accident of
my friend circle or if you've seen the
same sort of thing in the people that
you know
yeah that's interesting i think i've
probably got
good examples for both sides of the
fence
so one of the guys that i got close with
in austin was aubry marcus from onit and
one of the things that i realized with
him i've never been around someone
like
he is so competitive
about
[ __ ] everything man like he is the
quintessential
founder ceo startup
alpha male aggressive type of guy so not
in a not in like a um a confrontational
way but he's he's forthcoming so [ __ ]
we go into on it the gym and
me and one of the female trainers that's
there are going in and aubrey and his
mrs vilana are going in he's like oh
what why don't we have teams i'm like oh
yeah team suns sounds cool i see where
this team's gone
sounds fun uh we haven't warmed up we
haven't touched a single piece of
equipment right we've come in out of the
warm austin weather but we're
essentially cold he's like why don't we
do um
a thousand meters on the skierg for time
in teams of two and that can be the
warm-up like aubry that's that's that's
like a a really disgusting workout
that you that's the warm-up but he
wanted to he wanted to send it and i'm
like all right fair enough so we do it
and it's
like pedal to the metal immediately hard
and i just thought well that's why that
shows
somebody who has that real just in
everything he says i played pickleball i
went to his house when he played
pickleball and he wants to i was on his
team and he wants to [ __ ] win like it
was me and him taking on a couple of
other guys and he wants to he wants to
win hard and i'm like i
am not surprised that your company got
sold to unilever for a [ __ ] ton of money
because you are you are built to beat
the other guy um but then i have i have
buddies that are not like that at all
and have just as successful businesses
i wonder have you seen
that that corresponds to satisfaction
fulfillment or happiness in one
direction or the other or again just a
mixed bag i would say on average the
people that have the hustle culture
thing are less happy
um i think that that does correspond
that
most of that most of the motivation to
really really push it
comes from a place of insufficiency
it comes from a place of trying to fill
the hole with the work what about you
what do you think
that was my inkling but i can't tell if
i'm just making myself feel good for not
having sold my business to unilead
it's because i don't have a big enough
void inside of me that's filled by
league of legends well i
i can at least say with myself i work
the hardest
get the most fit do all the things when
i feel the worst
and that that's just me and i don't want
to put that on anybody else but
when i am recognizing how wonderful life
is
i tend to sit more and just look around
more and i tend to oh there goes my dog
come here bud
uh and i tend to to work less so i don't
i don't know what's going on with other
people and i know that aubry i don't
know the guy but he's clearly deep into
spirituality and all that other kind of
stuff yeah no he's um i think he's got
from the outside looking in he's got a
balance but
it's on average i would say that most of
the people that i know that are
incredibly driven are also
unhappy or they they have higher rates
of unhappiness which is like all right
is the price that you want to pay for
your success to be unhappy and [ __ ]
miserable well if success is supposed to
be in the service of happiness and by
making yourself into the person that can
be successful you make yourself
miserable
what what like just shortcut it just be
happy and don't worry about it
it seems to me that the work is actually
in service of preventing inner inner
reflection uh and
that's actually why stay so busy work so
hard is because it actu it does you the
favor of making you not have to look at
any of the other sorts of things which
is
it's it's doing you a solid at that
point
i've interacted with those types of
people and we don't
we don't
become close friends i just i had a
great conversation with you the other
day and it seemed like we're
similar in that regard which is we want
a level of material success but also
these questions of
for what why
what got me into this and what keeps me
in this did i already achieve the thing
that brought me here and if i did am i
gonna
am i just gonna set more moving goal
posts and convince myself that's the
game while living in a constant state of
i'm not there or is there ever an
arrival and there's a lot of
disagreement over this but to me i've
been i've been meditating not meditating
but thinking a lot about what is enough
in my life and if i look back 10 years
my life today i would have said would
have been enough forever so if it's not
then my mental scheme is screwed up
it's something something has gone wrong
and i need to reevaluate what started
this drive in the first place hedonic
adaptation is a hell of a drug man yeah
yeah it's crazy it is it is oh my god we
had a sales day for our course yesterday
that was near record highs
and the dopamine spike that i got from
it was instantaneous
and now a new baseline has been set and
i can watch these sorts of processes
unfold unfold in me
and it's so frustrating i just want to
want the things that make me fulfilled
but i want the things that don't
and so so what i've started trying to do
is how to deal with this is is to
control my environment don't spend time
on instagram get off of the things that
drive fomo in you uh it's almost and
maybe this isn't healthy putting
blinders on the things that trigger that
sense of lack or of missing out but
that's an interesting way to challenge
yourself right because you have
you can
decide to hide away from the things that
cause that and i always get conflicted
about whether or not that's a less
virtuous path than simply overcoming
them myself
should i feel this
a hundred percent i think that any time
you repress deny avoid you you have
cheated yourself in a degree of the most
fundamental solution to the problem so
if like if instagram triggers me and
makes me want to go out or be single or
do any stuff like that that is almost
like
the leaf of a plant that has a much
deeper root and so what i can do is i
can you know section off that leaf and
not look at that leaf but i haven't
addressed whatever it is that was
causing that to be
a
frustration or temptation in my life
uh and so yeah i have a mix my my
approach is is definitely mixed it's on
one hand avoid the things that trigger
me but also i'm trying to do
mdma therapy and all these kinds of
stuff where you do go in and you touch
the root and it has nothing to do with
instagram it has and everything to do
with you and your own feelings about
yourself and oftentimes early childhood
experiences and all that that fun stuff
all right so getting back to charisma
talk me yeah let's go back yeah let's
get that let's get the main thrust what
are the basic
principles that people should grasp if
they want to come across well when
they're communicating
i don't know that we've actually boiled
it down to the basic well the way that
we structure our teaching is that we
have within our course we have 30 days
and we start with first impressions talk
about confidence conversation uh and go
down the line
some of the first things that we talk
about which i presume are i guess the
most basic is that
when you're first interacting with
someone a great way to be a
conversational leader is to set the vibe
a level higher than you need to so
people often say how are you doing and
people often respond fine and i'm guilty
of this as well but if you want to
practice being charismatic find a way to
to amp yourself up to be fantastic or
great or amazing that immediately sets
the conversation off on a stronger foot
you also get these very very common
questions they're almost these social
niceties that we ask one another when
we're getting to know one another what
do you do for a living where are you
from and people take these gimme
questions and just submarine the
conversation i'm from philadelphia i'm a
consultant and so in just teaching
people look you already have habits
these aren't who you are can we just
make these start the conversation off on
a much stronger foot
so we have worksheets within the course
and we kind of talk about some of the
stuff on the youtube channel instead of
saying that you're a consultant realize
that the question the person is asking
you is please tell me anything
interesting about yourself with which i
can connect that's what they're saying
when they say where you from they're
going please say a city that i've been
to so i can say oh my god like the
weather is so great and do the favor of
sticking out some velcro for them to
attach onto so instead of saying
philadelphia i might say you know i grew
up on the east coast but i was always a
little bit of a crazy person so into
college i moved to brazil and did all
this crazy entrepreneurial stuff with a
bunch of friends but now i've realized
that i much prefer
uh summer sports and surfing and i live
in california within that answer there's
surfing there's sports there's
entrepreneurism there's adventure
there's traveling internationally
there's all these different directions
that the person that you're speaking to
can listen to and decide to hook into
and what happens is when you give them
five six seven options in a three
sentence answer you're going to
naturally go down conversations that
both people are more interested in so
you might find yourself with one person
talking about extreme sports and you're
super fascinated on that on the other
hand you're talking about something else
when we started talking you had in your
bio
club promoter or something like that the
first question i asked you was like yo
tell me about club promoting because
that was something that i did when i was
in new york uh and so when you give
people more about you to hook into early
on in conversation that helps
tremendously another big thing in
conversation
is that we often take
questions to literally again what people
are trying to do when they're meeting
one another is just suss out a vibe and
so if you're answering every question
very literally the vibe that you're
giving is this is an interview
you know and sometimes that's great when
you're diving down into the values that
you have and that they have and you can
really connect over that but oftentimes
just answering one of the questions in a
non-literal fashion sets the vibe of i'm
here to have fun and this is especially
important if you're out at a nightclub
or something like that so when someone
asks you where you're from in a
nightclub you don't have to give them
the whole philadelphia spiel you can say
you know can't you tell that i'm from
the congo or you know something
something ridiculous that can't possibly
be true given your skin tone and that
sets the tone of the conversation to go
down a much more fun interesting vibe so
that's
there's a lot that we talk about but
really
starting an interaction in the direction
you'd like it to head and being
cognizant of that is a large part of the
beginnings of what we teach because then
the conversation can kind of just take
care of itself people want to have much
more fun that they're having and so if
you could be the person that breaks them
out of the serious moment whether it's
via text or in conversation they're
going to appreciate you want you around
more and it seems like a superpower but
all you're doing is not taking questions
literally if that's all you did you
would see that
and people are afraid to do it in the
corporate world that's the other thing
this is one of the things that got me
ahead in work was just
not
not buying into the implicit social
norms of the workplace so that when you
came in you were supposed to be very
serious
being able to have fun in that sort of
an environment is what ingratiated me to
the bosses made them much more amenable
when i left they wound up paying me a
lot of money to work as an at-home
consultant it just it worked out
fantastically and it was not because i
was the best consultant it was because
we built a human relationship instead of
a corporate relationship so again those
are the types of things that just work
in almost any sort of environment dating
professional whatever
it's crazy how much this sort of stuff
feels like it would make someone stand
out you know they're relatively easy
principles to follow and yet
you know that if somebody was to do this
and deliver effectively on a regular
basis
that they would be
in probably the top five percent of
communicators top five percent of funny
people that you know
yeah yeah i and and again within this
it's funny that you say this because
there still is what i talk about the
authentic type and joe rogan happens to
be a comedian as well but there are
people that
don't have to do this thing this is one
tip amongst many what you can do is when
asked a serious question give tough
answers you know that are honest and
over time you will establish a
reputation as somebody that is very
authentic that people trust and like for
different reasons and if you're out
there listening you can think of
somebody right now that probably fits
the bill
so you don't have to do any one of these
things it's about finding the one that
when you try it on feels good for you
and that you can lean into more and good
things tend to happen how much do you
think that people can change their
charisma levels so if someone feels shy
or introverted how much have you found
that people can change this are people
infinitely malleable when it comes to
their charisma level
no no i don't think you're likely to get
a mark zuckerberg to
a will smith i don't like i don't think
that's going to happen with all the
media training in the world but mark
zuckerberg has gotten better and i
actually think if he really cared to
could get become a much stronger
communicator than he is so
anybody can get
considerably better they can
i think dramatically in most cases
improve their dating life their
friendship circles the confidence and
happiness that they feel in a social
environment but it's not infinitely
malleable uh there are some people that
i look at like russell brand
is a conversational genius i i try to
break down what people do and with so
many people i can put their responses
into buckets like tom holland is going
to respond with a funny story you know
rdj is gonna make a quip like and you
can emulate those styles and get them
russell's
spontaneity and his almost the fact that
he's got so many different jokes and
references that he leans into i i gush
over him all the time but i i wish i
could do what he could do and i can't
capture it in a simple model like i can
with some other people uh so there's
definitely
levels and i i can't do what he does
under any circumstances he's like a
lexical jiu jitsu black belt yes yes and
he's capable of going from hilarious
commentary to very value driven you know
what is the purpose of life within the
span of two sentences which is
super attractive because that's i think
where a lot of us live we want to have
fun but we're also interested in in the
deeper meaning of things
how would you characterize some of the
trends given the fact that you've broken
down russell brand a bunch of times i've
enjoyed some of the videos that you've
done on him what are some of the
principles that we can learn from
russell brand or what some of the uh
characteristics that he relies on
oh man he's
so there's a lot so there's there's the
flirtatious pre
uh enlightenment russell brand which is
if you look at what he does he treats
everyone men and women flirtatiously
which is a general principle for dating
if you want to be a better flirt you
have to flirt with everybody you have to
flirt with men and compliment them you
have to flirt with the older woman who
you're definitely not attracted to and
then of course he flirts with the
beautiful women's who he's sometimes
interviewing and they're they're
giggling about it so that's one of the
things that he does is flirts with the
entire world and what that means is he's
cheeky he's playful he uh does this we
have a breakdown of push pull where he
oftentimes will
give you a heartfelt compliment but then
relieve the tension at the end of it by
just saying some sort of uh
a joke that that relieves attention and
you can see what we're talking about in
the video i can't think of what he
actually does right now
uh so that's one of the big things that
he does
he
also and i guess i don't i have never
been able to figure out how and why he
makes these decisions depending on the
question that you ask him you could get
a totally ridiculous joke answer or the
most sincere
value-driven
heartfelt connection
that that you would ever expect and i
can't figure out how and why he makes
the that decision but he does and it
makes him
very fascinating to listen to because
you don't know what's going to come up
from him well that unpredictability
suggests authenticity
it suggests that there isn't an agenda
behind this because you can't predict oh
russell's got asked a question about god
here we go again with the story from
when he was five years old or whatever
yeah and and you know there's people
that i
i love tony robbins but he is
so predictable
if you listen to a tony robbins
interview like i have i've listened to
all of them he's got 30 or 40 stories
and depending on what you ask you're go
you're going to hear one of those
stories told in the same way with the
same punchline because as an educator
and teacher he knows that it has an
intended effect but it definitely does
leave me as someone who has watched a
lot of him wondering if i've ever seen
the real him if i've ever seen behind
that
performative social curtain still love
the guy but yeah you're right it it
totally suggests authenticity when
it seems as if he's genuinely doesn't
know what he's gonna say before he says
it it's whatever is surging inside him
in that moment what about the new
russell brand post
dmt post enlightenment
yeah so he's i think still has a lot of
it he's not as flirtatious as he used to
be
i think what he does a fantastic job of
is
being authentic in his positions like
you know where he stands politically but
he can sit down with a candace owens
and be
non-judgmental not assume that she is an
evil person trying to destroy the world
and maintain
a playfulness and curiosity in the face
of ideas that are bitterly opposed to
his ideals and i think that that is
incredibly rare when you see candace
owens talk to anyone else who disagrees
with her because it's going to fall
apart quickly on both sides they're both
going to accuse each other of bad faith
he's genuinely able to or generally able
to maintain
a good faith vibe in any sort of
political or spiritual disagreement
which i think is comes from a place of
actually not thinking that he has all
the answers which you can't fake dude
that's exactly what i had in my head the
fact that he's got strong opinions held
loosely not loose opinions held strongly
yeah yeah um so i could gush about him
over and over yeah all right so let's
get back to shyness let's get away from
russell brand and his turbo penis um
what about if someone is feeling shy
they don't have a lot of social
confidence how can someone overcome that
how can they develop more
so
i think that uh we talk often about how
courage is a muscle and it's not the
answer that a lot of people want to get
but i think progressive exposure therapy
is it really is the way and so again in
the course we start very easy if you're
shy
you're probably biting your tongue often
not saying that you think and you're
probably mistaking that for i don't have
anything to say nothing comes to mind
the truth is the filter in your head is
so high
that nothing breaks through that as
being worthy of being said and so when
we're talking to shy people what we
often tell them to do is with
say that you're in a situation with a
taxi driver or someone else who's
working for you a waiter a cashier
say one extra sentence right so the
normal thing is that'll be 592. you give
them your thing but something is in your
head
there's a magazine cover there the
weather is hot uh they have a nice
earring or something say one extra thing
and what we're trying to teach them to
do is to lower that filter of what would
be acceptable to say to someone now
there are people that have the reverse
problem where they blabber on and on and
on and we need to teach them to be a bit
more selective but when you're shy i
think that's oftentimes the biggest
problem is that
you
think that the things that you have to
say are such crap that you communicate
that with every fiber of your being and
so once you're saying them then we have
to teach okay
say with your chest say it like you mean
it don't don't trail off at the end of
sentences if you're in a group
conversation
do not let someone cut you off until you
hit a period so if you're mid
conversation with someone and you're
finishing your thought and they jump in
you have to get to the end of it like
now and then they can take over so it's
not about being a conversational bully
it's about learning to
take up conversational space in a way
that is assertive uh so that's
that's a very common thing that we see
with shy people is that they're
reluctant to do that but just a handful
of
of models like those goes a long way and
also like they didn't cut me off a
second time they realized that i wasn't
going to just disappear and you know
they feel very happy about it
what about the tailing off at the end of
sentences thing that's definitely
something that i notice people do if
they're uncomfortable in a social
situation or a little bit shy how can
people overcome that
what the general rule is you have to
finish it with the same decibel level
that you started it with you've you've
got to find a way and
the way that we teach people is like
look these are new habits when you're
learning them they might not feel like
you it's gonna feel uncomfortable you're
gonna go this charisma thing isn't for
me so just focus on one thing per day
our videos are in part entertainment
they've got five six things if you try
to do that all you are going to live in
your head we want you to be in the
conversation reacting listening but also
i do want you thinking of one thing that
you're gonna do differently that day and
so what we do in the course is we
structure it differently so you have one
thing for each day but if you're a shy
person and you're out there the thing
that you might think of for today is
if i'm in a group setting this evening
make sure that i finish any sentence
before i yield the floor and that's it
and then you can do whatever you want
you could be awkward with your body
language you could make crappy eye
contact you could say dumb things but
you just focus on that and over time
you're stacking these habits on top of
each other such that when you get five
six seven eight of these together
you really do have a much more powerful
personality
talk to me about the tension between
needing to learn a skill in
communication
and needing to be sufficiently in the
conversation to be able to flow through
things because you have this system one
system two dynamic going on here right
we need to be very deliberate system two
i'm thinking about it oh [ __ ] i'm
thinking about it i'm thinking about it
so much that i realize i haven't moved
my body for the last three minutes i've
been constantly thinking about finishing
my sentences at the same [ __ ] decibel
level because of that charlie guy yeah
yeah so and this this is attention and i
have
the ways that i hear people say to
relieve it just be yourself i find art
do not actually lead to growth they
might lead to evolution over time as
things go back but if you want to
deliberately grow i think you have to
deal with this tension
the way that we've done it is just by
having one thing that you're focusing on
per day and it would be one small thing
and sometimes it's literally just a
thing that occurs at the beginning of an
interaction like i'm gonna say my answer
to where are you from like the one that
i practiced and built as opposed to the
one that is reflexive uh and so that's
how we do it so that there definitely is
some time where i'm taking you out of
the flow of conversation and i recognize
that but i do i have not found a better
way to learn a skill i think it requires
deliberate i don't know it's system one
or two it requires that deliberate
removing yourself from the flow of how
things have always been
a little bit for a period of time uh
there's an awesome awesome story about
tiger woods when he was
early in his career and he realized that
he had some um
how would you say perversions in his
swing he had some professional
um he had some perversions in his swing
that was causing him to be less accurate
and less consistent than he needed to be
and the decision was look
if you want to be the best in the world
we need to rebuild your swing
from scratch
and this meant that he had to take a
bunch of steps back he'd stop being
system one he could have gone on being
the perfectly adequate type version of
tiger woods for the rest of his career
without having to do this so he
purposefully had to get worse before he
could get better because he was going to
have to relearn all of the different
things and i kind of feel like there's
an analogy to draw here between this and
purposeful conversationalizing
100 and i don't know how tiger went
about that and maybe maybe there is a
better way that i've yet to discover but
it's the way that i did it because i was
getting overwhelmed when i was trying to
do everything i remember just being like
okay and you stand like this and you do
this and all of a sudden i could be in
his social interaction and not have been
there literally at all i was just
totally in the realm of thinking
planning scheming in my head and so that
didn't work which is why we went back to
the let's take one element of the swing
at a time let's start with just doing
what we do with a different grip let's
now let's worry about the hips now and
and that was how
over time i was able to still be an
interaction still be in my head a little
bit but
building towards what wound up becoming
a very different way
after months and years of doing this of
of being generally yeah and i'm guessing
that reps repetitions of this oh gosh
yeah and
you nailed it yeah i'm forgetting the
most basic stuff and i appreciate you
bringing it up it truly is just reps uh
the nice thing is that
you know how there's beginner gains in
the gym because nobody focuses on this
stuff it comes so quickly this is not
like
it's easier than learning an instrument
it's easier than than putting on muscle
mass
and it's because it's it's like if you
lived in a world where no one worked out
how quickly could you go to the gym
before your body made you exceptional
like it wouldn't take very long and
that's the world that we live in with
regards to charisma is nobody's working
on it so all you have to do is is this
very small amount before people are
going to start to notice that you're in
an elite tier which is awesome and
that's that's not uh anything to do with
what we teach but just the fact that
there's almost no competition the bar is
set
the bar is low yeah
all right so you guys started out one of
the initial reasons that you wanted to
get better at communicating was to be
better with women and there will be a
lot of guys that want to improve their
ability to talk to girls what are the
principles of men communicating
attractively to women
so we have broken down uh the flirting
process let's see if i can do this it's
been a long time since i've had to get
out there and do this
the first piece
[Laughter]
so the first piece of it is just
interest that we think about and let's
pretend that you're in a bar or
something uh what we're trying to avoid
in this stage is i have to go to the
bathroom i'm just bored of you and so
when we're talking about this this is
the playful stuff that we mentioned it's
a lot of the things with where do you
what do you do where are you from
finding ways to be interesting this
isn't sexy necessarily this isn't i want
to hook up with you it's just i want
this interaction to continue
the second piece that i think a lot of
guys skip out on is having genuine
standards uh
when you receive a letter from harvard
university that you've been accepted it
feels wonderful when you receive a
letter from the community college that
takes 100 of the people it doesn't feel
good and the truth about dating like it
or not is that we often date people to
affirm things about ourselves so when
you have no standards for this other
person and they feel like
they could have been anyone like truly
it was their shape that attracted you to
them
it doesn't
generate any sort of interest in you but
if you're indicating through interaction
for instance
if you're out at a bar or a club and
somebody is rude to a waiter or a
waitress or bartender you go oh my god i
can't stand people who do that if i
would you know i don't care how
beautiful or fun or sexy you are like
when i see that kind of behavior it's a
total turn off just as an aside in the
conversation that's communicating to the
person that
they care about my personality right and
now the thing is you want to have
genuine standards so
this is easier for people who have dated
and who have had you know perhaps dated
something they were very attracted to
who had personality traits that they
didn't really like if you can go through
your history and ask yourself what are
the things that really do attract me to
people that are not sexuality or you
know shape based things what are the
things that that make me uh repulsed and
list those out and find ways to
incorporate those into conversation for
instance
i have most enjoyed my relationships
with women who were incredibly
affectionate so when someone early in an
interaction says i'm a hugger i go oh my
god i'm going to love you like i'm i'm
the same way i can't stand people that
just want to like touch on the shoulder
say hello we're like high five every
time and that communicates to them that
there are things that i am selecting for
and you actually are within that
category now it is crucial here to this
is not a strategy to fake right if
you're just saying these things and
really it's like no it's you just have
the shape and the look it's not going to
work nearly as well
and it's also just not good for you
you're going to wind up in the
relationship that sucks
and then the last piece is sexual
tension
and i think this is the part that is
probably most uncomfortable for a lot of
guys is being able to sit in a sexually
tense scenario which might be lingering
on eye contact with someone interaction
with a smirk on your face it might be
dancing close
without having to crack a joke
uh
being able to manage that sexual tension
while sometimes relieving it with that
playful push-pull stuff is is
does not come natural
to most people they try to escape it as
soon as they feel it and therefore
they're never sitting with that
discomfort it's hard
oh yeah and it's it is tense it's it's
this in-between stage of do you like me
do i like you are we gonna kiss or are
we just looking into each other's eyes
and being able to hold that and enjoy
that
is something that
we talk about it takes some time to
develop but there are some things that
you can do so for instance
most people if they go on a date say you
match someone on tinder or hinge they'll
go to a bar they'll sit down on opposite
sides of a booth talk about work you
know and then they'll okay at the end of
the night
well i hope you had a good time and
there's been no sexual tension built
versus if you go to the bar you say hey
let's sit over here you sit at the bar
while you're communicating with them you
put your hand on their hand when they
make a joke you say i love that you give
them a hug you know you you know hold
their their arm while you're telling a
story to demonstrate what somebody did
you are building this sort of uh
this physical tension between the two of
you that gets more and more comfortable
and allows for those sort of close is it
happening isn't it happening
interactions and you're not putting all
the weight from going from zero to 60
with the good night kiss at the doorstep
which feels awful and it's just an
amount of like
discomfort that is that is not fun for
anybody to experience so those are those
are the sort of the buckets that we that
i think about at least when i'm talking
about it and what i try to ask guys
specifically to do because it's a
different scenario with girls
is to think about
where they are
not
uh going to the next level and it's like
oh they're just walking away from me as
i start conversations like okay let's
talk about being more interesting in
conversation or i've never actually
uh you know i'm hitting on girls and i'm
being fun and interesting but they have
a sense that i'm just a player and they
don't want to talk to me it's like well
you've got no standards and then so
going through those using that as a
diagnostic tool is is something that we
do
i think guys are probably quite fearful
about running out of stuff to say as
well have you got strategies for small
talk
yeah so uh one there's there's a couple
of different videos in terms of
women uh specifically in flirting
scenarios this is the hardest things my
brain is like this and you've seen in
this interaction i'm a logistical person
when you ask me a question i want to
answer it literally
the best thing for small talk is to
recognize that especially on a date or
in a borrower club they just want to
vibe you don't have to have topics it's
not about [ __ ] podcasts work yeah
it's it's a podcast it's not supposed to
be that it's supposed to be fun playful
world building so uh
you know if she says oh my god
like you went to jamaica i studied
abroad there but like oh my god
fantastic after this bar we're going to
the airport we're going to get on a
plane we're going to go scuba diving
we'll be there tomorrow morning we're
going to have to fund this so somehow i
don't know i'm going to have to take up
a job selling lucy cigarettes
on the street whatever you're just like
just this playful world building is a
way that men tend not to instinctively
communicate what do you mean by world
building
uh what i just created was almost an
improvisational comedy
scenario like we're going to go here
here's what's going to happen obviously
none of this is real this is this is i'm
definitely not going to sell lucy
cigarettes to fund a plane ride for
tomorrow but when you can build these
fake
fun obviously not real fantasy scenarios
that people participate in and sometimes
men do this with their with their good
friends when they're all in a group of
people you know that would be like if
blah blah blah oh my god when you do
that with women in fun ways that tends
to
uh set the vibe to be this fun flirty
thing that she can contribute to and say
well we're not going to stay in the same
room tonight be like perfect i'm going
to get a i'm going to have the penthouse
and you could sleep in you know the
water closet or whatever and no i don't
want to sleep in the water closet so
these these are the types of things that
are ridiculous that most men would never
think about doing in conversation but
that are genuinely fun once you
try on this new style of of conversing
now of course
there's still going to be time for
what do you do where are you from what's
your work but especially in a bar
nightclub scenario which i think what
i'm tending towards more
if you lead with here's my cool job i
work at goldman sachs that's incredibly
boring i can't tell you the number of
guys in new york i saw who started by
handing out business cards instead of
doing this fun stuff first and then
they'll be like who are you tell me
about yourself and then at that point
the goldman sachs thing actually comes
in as a patent interrupt and you're like
oh holy [ __ ] like he's actually funny
and interesting and he's prepared to
sell loose cigarettes
and he's got a job at an investment bank
yes exactly and the best way then when
you're talking about you know okay i
work in investment bank is to speak to
your values again people want to know
your vibe and your values not just the
logistics of what you do so if you say i
work at goldman sachs a much stronger
way is to think what drove me hopefully
it's not just a sense of greed but like
you know i grew up poor and i always
wanted to be able to take care of my mom
and family so like you know i don't want
to be an investment banker for the rest
of my life but it's helping me to one
day buy a house for my mom like that if
if true so attractive so
so much more engaging than i'm a banker
at goldman sachs so if you're setting a
vibe or sharing your values those are
two very strong modes of conversation to
be in compared to just answering
questions logistically honestly
yeah that's an interesting one man i am
i'm interested to find out what you
think most men go wrong when approaching
women and if there's girls that are
watching they can put some of their
nightmare scenarios down in the comments
below as well um women have a very
different understanding of this because
they're when they think what goes wrong
with men they're selecting for the men
that have approached them right and so
they're going oh they were way too pushy
way too forward they said this goofy
thing they did some r nice guys stuff
where they told me like they could be my
boyfriend and i'd never have to go cold
the truth is most guys are are not in
that category they're not walking up to
you they're thinking about it uh
but not doing it right so that's that's
by fault it's 99.9 that's 99.9
is not engaging in conversation uh so
that's definitely the the thing that
most of them do wrong though when women
think about what do most men do wrong
they're going to go to the horror
stories of the 0.1 percent they just
come in like complete arrogant asses
so yeah it's it's not
it's disqualifying yourself before
before you've spoken to someone uh and
there's a hundred different
ways to speak to someone mentalities
that can help but
uh going in with a vibe of curiosity and
again flirt with the world i think one
of the things that men do wrong is that
they try to be these snipers which is
like these boring people who walk
through life not talking to anyone not
engaging with the cashier and then
they're going to see the most beautiful
woman at the bar who is surrounded by
people who want to speak to her and
they're going to go now i'm going to
turn it on yeah by the power of gray
school they decide to pick up a [ __ ]
right this it's time to turn it on it's
time to do it yeah and then they they
hulk out and and just do it that's not
how it's ever been with me i haven't
seen it done that way it
it's by flirting with the world it's by
recognizing that the person that you
should flirt with is the next person you
interact with and whether that's uh
someone in your apartment building as
you're taking the elevator who is an
older gentleman like being that outgoing
fun friendly person setting a vibe
goofing off
and then just happening to be near the
person that you're interested in is
going to be much much more powerful
because it's not something that you've
got to like gear up for it's something
that is going to be habituated into the
way that you're used to speaking with
people it won't feel like such a stretch
so generally other than the uh how would
you say misinterpreting purposefully
misinterpreting the question and giving
a silly answer are there some other easy
ways that people can add humor into
conversations
yeah um okay so how do we add humor into
conversations what i see
i'm coming back to a lot of the the same
things which is your initial
conversational tracks are going to be
totally similar and they already are
totally similar people say the same
things if you're in college they want to
know what major you have if they're if
you're in the workforce they want to
know what you do for a living so having
both an answer that is true and reveals
your values and a playful answer to a
lot of these different things and you
can answer what are the three questions
that you could ask the most
i literally went out and split tested
these different things and would just
just answer different stuff
at different times in the night club or
something like that so that is one that
you can do because those are just going
to be free gimmes it's kind of like
uncle jokes the thing the uncle's just
prepared for you to say something
and you have you have a ready-made
response uh in terms of more spontaneous
conversational stuff there's a lot of
different types of humor one of the
russell brand is very fast clever call
back witty that's tougher to implement
an easy one is to say the opposite and
it sounds dumb but if it's a super hot
day and everyone's bitching about how
hot it is and you go out you're like
man it's cold out here i swear to god
you will get a chuckle from people
because what what humor is in many cases
is just when the unexpected occurs it
causes a chuckle so it's not the
funniest way to be funny you know you
can be witty and clever and have
interesting callbacks but
saying the opposite is a very easy way
to just to get laughs and chuckles and
and insert humor if you're not the other
thing that i recommend people do because
i do think that it's
our brains
i guess this is more system one just
automatic is you can prime yourself so
what one of rather than thinking of
humor if i think how i did it it wasn't
by purposely working in
uh saying the opposite necessarily it
was by watching a lot of chris pratt
before i would go out i just like
watched 10 minutes and i'd watch some
step brothers best of clips and put
myself in that mode of
ridiculous
non-sequitur statement and i would just
talk about prestige worldwide and screw
you know investors possibly you
and point of people and just lift these
lines straight out of movies into
context that it didn't make any sense
and that actually worked really well
because it was i was enjoying it i was
referencing movies that i had fun with
and i was
not taking all of the words that chris
pratt would said but his general
demeanor was was coming through so yeah
trying to make like your fifth best
friend the comedian that you most enjoy
and the vibe that you want to have and
just watching them for 10-15 minutes
before going into a social interaction
was was actually the way that i did it
that's a really cool way to use like
recency bias to
influence because it's
we can't all be tim dillon
you know
that ability to be
who i think actually now tim is
as far as i can see one of the quickest
guys
that's doing sort of conversations on
this circuit like tim's the gay russell
brand at the moment if you hear him on
rogan his ability his ability to be
unbelievably rapid do you see the
most recent rogan where he said
do you think that there's other epstein
islands and he's like yeah better ones
hilton's building them now there's just
slides where the kids go immediately
down and they're straight into a furnace
and you're like holy [ __ ] that was off
the cuff that's disgusting so there is
if you're serious about humor and again
you don't with this charisma stuff uh
storytelling humor you don't need to be
excellent you truly the bar is so low
you could say the opposite and you'll be
the funniest person in a group of most
people but if you really want to go deep
in humor improv comedy classes are
awesome i used to take these uh these
classes
at the pit in new york and there was one
on the west side in los angeles they
train you to we talked about world
building for flirting like how to
structure a thing create a scene all
that kind of stuff but
the specificity that tim dillon is
driving into is not and the tags that he
adds to that right it's not just oh yeah
there's better islands he's got the
slide into the furnace those are those
are uh there's principles of comedy that
guide that and it takes a long time to
be able to do it that quickly but you
can develop that skill through practice
and they will teach you almost
everything you need to know about that
in an improv comedy class if it's if
it's any good so that's another thing
like if you really want to be funnier
improv comedy is is where i would start
so so other than russell brand who are
some of your favorite communicators
tony robbins is excellent and it's it's
the criticism i have is also his
strength is that he has a story for
every situation and it's the type of
story that has been split test over 40
years to elicit the most powerful
reaction from you uh so he's a fantastic
communicator if
probably the best person that i can
think of for inspiring someone to change
in a 20-minute conversation like he can
get in there
move your
your motivators around and leave you and
you'll be on a different path oprah
winfrey is amazing
she
i she's before my time but having
watched some of her interviews she just
gets people to cry and open up and has
and can do it in front of a studio
audience which is incredible which the
fact that she can create this safe this
bubble of safety around her in the chair
even when people are watching i think
speaks to
the power of her communication style uh
there was i mean bill clinton was
incredible back in the day the stories
that you read about bill clinton and the
way that he would make you feel like the
only person in the room even if you were
just in a line of people with whom he
was shaking hands i don't know if you've
ever read any of those but there's
no what were the principles that people
um oh people tested that to be
so people don't know they were just
convinced that he wanted to be their
friend
they were just totally like but he said
when he shook their hand they knew that
they had a moment with him and that they
were the most important person there and
everybody
thought that yes i can't find footage of
this um i see i've seen some but there's
not a ton of footage that i've been able
to dig up i've been trying to go what is
that but from what i can see it's that
he
he's from the south he's slow he's a
little bit more deliberate and he will
spend more time with people and also
made it a point every day to study
people's names would remember the name
of every single person such that if he
shook your hand at the beginning of a
fundraiser and learned two things about
you he had trained his memory at the end
to be like and by the way i hope your
son gets into ut and you know would say
the two things that you spoke about back
to you
and that is again extremely powerful
takes practice like he literally would
work on the names of people apparently
in the oval office that he had met and
refresh himself on that kind of stuff
there's a story about alex ferguson the
manchester united manager for a very
long time and he had a period when he
first joined the club
and he needed to get the players on side
i feel like he joined in turmoil or
something that there was it was a little
bit of a high pressure situation and he
really really needed to get all of the
players on side really really quickly
and he went round and was talking to one
particular player and said look
you are the most important player on the
pitch today it is all about you and then
it only took until the end of the season
for the lads to start talking to each
other and find out that he'd said that
to every single [ __ ] one of them
yeah and i think that was the power of
bill clinton you never had to say it so
they could never check it with anyone
else it was just a sense that and you
know that's the hack as you just lied to
people uh but he really did take the
time to make people feel special which
is which is impressive uh and then one
more that comes to mind is kevin hart
he
i think kevin hart is five foot two and
he hangs out with basketball players
that are seven foot two and you can
watch
there is an innate power differential
when you're standing like this to speak
to someone that cannot be avoided but he
so quickly
takes control of these groups of like
boisterous basketball players such that
he has them listening to what he's
saying and they're reacting to
his topics of conversation and his jokes
he is incredible and whenever people
point to like i'm too short for this i
always point it back to kevin hart like
look i don't know how many people in
your life are two feet taller than you
but this guy is capable of uh hanging
with shaq and making shaq and all of his
friends love him so he's got something
special as well
did you see that video of shapiro doing
a debate and this guy comes up and asks
a question and says why is it that you
say on your wikipedia that you're 5'10
when you're foot four and shapiro
immediately goes how tall are you and he
goes five foot ten he goes okay come up
here comes up and stands up and bends
taller than him dude it's so [ __ ]
funny that [ __ ] is so [ __ ] funny you
need to you need to check it out it's so
good
oh god that's like that's like um
i mean that's a bold move by shapiro
because he didn't know what that guy was
going to say in response and that guy
just flubbed it just tell the truth man
and just say how tall you are
so [ __ ] i mean on the topic shapiro's
phenomenal like he's one of the quickest
guy he genuinely is like listening to
something at one and a half time speed
uh but yeah i can't i can't normally
but he is quick
yeah yeah um no i haven't so i've looked
at his communication style and i do
think
he is obviously very smart i watch him
and i did a video on his debate tactics
i've
i think that because he is a public
debater he he has been trained to go for
the dunk you know what i mean like
that's that's a dunk he didn't address
the question he didn't
uh
handle it logically he dunked and in
discrediting the person who asked the
question
won the social
uh approval of the crowd so
when i watch him i
i see
a lot oftentimes more
not necessarily sound logic which he may
have as well at his disposal but
shortcut dunk tactics to to discredit
the other side make them look foolish
etc was it you was it one of your videos
that said
were you being critical around modern
debating and saying that
one of the sad things or one of the
interesting quirks about modern debates
is that it's not necessarily the person
that has the best position it's the
person that can get two or three laughs
big laughs during a debate everybody
seems to come away thinking that they
won
yes yes we've talked about that in
several videos i mean that's donald
trump you know when asked the question
about his relationship to women uh only
roger o'donnell
he
he you know effectively but that's what
it is that is communication is
the meta-narrative of that interaction
is her saying this is an important
question and he said no it isn't and the
audience said i'm on his side and rather
than
addressing he he just
took the frame spun it on its head and
said i i win and was able to do that
throughout all of the campaign which is
really interesting but i do think that
there's something to be said for
taking the opponents in good faith and
assuming the frames that they give to
you and saying maybe there's maybe i
will play within your frame and try to
deal with it now there are times when
the frame which is presented to you is
on its face ludicrous and you need to
disrupt it in the way that donald trump
did and ben shapiro did because that
question is jordan
and yeah exactly and that's the question
that ben shapiro was asking that's kind
of what he said it's it wasn't a
sincere good faith question it doesn't
sound like why do you say this and he
said you're a dick and then the audience
agreed with him for you know he said
you're a hypocritical dick and that was
the uh
that was the actual communication and
sometimes that's very useful to do is to
ask yourself not what are they saying
what is the frame of what they're saying
back and forth to one another and that
and that gives you some indication of
uh if the conversation is happening in
good faith or if it's just two people
rejecting the form
that the other one is throwing back at
them i suppose it must be useful in a
debate to have a little bit of humor as
a
pressure release valve you know like he
was saying
some people during sexual tension will
make a joke or do a thing or look away
or laugh or whatever because they can't
deal with that tension but sometimes in
a debate using that humor can actually
or in a difficult conversation i imagine
as well like a disagreement or
something's getting a bit heated you can
use that to just a little bit a little
bit off
yeah i think it was i think it was
stephen fry maybe at the monk debates
who was just fantastic and
it
especially was the only funny person on
stage yes with two pitch sides that are
sometimes throwing barbs at one another
i thought that he i was like
regardless of who you came here liking
you probably left
thinking that you could listen to that
guy and that he wasn't a monster and
that that is impressive and i think
you're totally right which is
when things get super heated there's a
time to go okay tension off and it's the
same thing with sexual tension like
there is a time to go and we need to
crack a joke now but most people just
their threshold for that is uh as soon
as they start making eye contact like
run away
all right i want to change tac a little
bit now can you tell me
this story about getting your entire
family to take mdma
oh gosh yeah
um so a couple years ago i'll start i i
took ayahuasca for the first time after
a breakup and it was very impactful the
breakup is what drove me there and what
i took from it was much much more than
that so i continued down this path of
psychedelic therapy
having never done any sort of drugs and
having been off alcohol for eight years
at that point so this was like a big
deal for me
uh
and after experimenting with ayahuasca
5mu dmt
uh psilocybin and then mdma i found that
mdma was the one that was easiest to
recommend to new newbies and that's
because mdma unlike ayahuasca is
oftentimes going to give you a
historical
view of your life versus ayahuasca you
might see shapes and the elves and dmt
and it's like what the hell
mdma is like a warm blanket being
wrapped around you that gives you the
courage to dive into
your traumas and what you made of them
uh
and oftentimes the things that come up
are the things that you think i dealt
with that you know that's totally fine
and out of the way so i got a lot of
awesome stuff which would take a long
time to talk about from my experiences
and one by one went to my family and
said i really want you to do this and
what ultimately i think got them to
agree
was
the changes that they saw in me
particularly my dad
was
didn't want to go but a lot of what was
coming for me in these experiences was
wanting more of a connection with him
and it was tough for me even to say to
him that like
i started telling him like a charismatic
person like you know this would be good
for you and i think it would be good for
your life and you know you would enjoy
this and what ultimately i think moved
him was the authentic truth which is
i need you to do this so i can feel
close to you and that that was like very
[ __ ] hard for me to say with the
quaver in my voice near tears and i
think that was what ultimately got him
to do it in any event last august we all
did it um
together and it was
[ __ ] wild man it's it was wild
talk me through the morning of waking up
and when you look at your calendar for
the day
you have
take mdma with my entire family like
what what does that feel like
so we were we were in big bear um and we
got a little cabin with a therapist to
to help coach us through the experience
i was so
nervous man i barely needed to take mdma
i was on the verge i was shaking and on
the vert like i was i was ready to crack
already um so within minutes of taking
it i was like
you know crying and talking about stuff
and no what i felt was um i'm the oldest
son and what i felt was
terror at the failings of my younger
siblings because i was in the position
of having to have you know of k not of
caretaker but of like i should have
known better
and
terror at you know telling my parents
the disappointments and that i that i
had with them because they were to me
were in the position of that so i was
scared on both sides mostly scared of of
getting it from my younger brother and
sister for the let downs that that i've
had over the years
um
but yeah it was it was a scary
exhilarating experience and
it was one that i was
there's a lot that i could say about it
but i think what the good that came of
it
briefly
is that i
assumed
the correct role in the family of oldest
sibling and i think what i had done was
assume a triangulated role in between my
mom and my dad as like referee of their
interactions i i was like a third parent
judgmental of the brother and sister
separate from them uh and what i
expressed to everybody is like i want to
be
a brother and a son
not a
guru which is what i am yeah which is
what i am on youtube you know everybody
listens to me and that's kind of the
dynamic that has been set up in the
family like i don't want this i did this
as a coping mechanism for what was
happening like that i needed to to take
this place and so i want to
learn from the wisdom of my mom and dad
and
not have a separate power differential
between my brother and my sister and and
fit in that so there was a lot that
happened but it was
it was awesome and i got a lot of what i
needed and honest to god afterward i
felt like
a life's purpose was lifted off my
shoulders i was like i [ __ ] did it if
i just died today
i did what i had to do um
and so it was it was awesome and it was
a culmination of a lot of different
things and i highly
recommend exploring the idea of
psychedelic therapy i don't i don't
recommend it for everyone and it's not
there's definite uh contra indicators
but it has been
the most powerful
thing
of the last five to ten years and the
only thing comparable to it is the
realization that i could uh consciously
change myself and now i'm getting to the
realization that my unconscious is most
of me so so that's what i kind of have
to address is not all the things that i
think about but the things that just are
the case about me
man that's so beautiful i'm really
really happy to hear
the progress that you made for you and
your family it's like really gorgeous
and
puts into perspective the work that can
be done
you know there's this strange situation
that occurs
may have been early for you it sounds
like it might have been a little bit
early for you but there's a strange
situation that everybody goes through at
some point
when they stop being
the one
who
is not at the mercy of their parents but
with their parents being the wisdom
givers
and that power dynamic flips
and it's now the parents that are coming
to them for
help with technology for concerns that
they have around
what's going to happen next for i've
left my job for i want to change my
career for when am i going to retire for
whatever it might be
and that navigating that change of
polarity because it just happens
just one day you're having a
conversation with your parents and you
go yeah
i'm steering
the ship of this interaction
mostly now
yeah and only
five or ten years ago i was completely
like behest to your whims and i i was
basically just this blob this like
useless blob that that you would give a
lift to
sport practice or whatever
and it's so bizarre that dynamic
changing is so
strange and and and odd to to navigate
yeah i mean there's there's so many
reactions that i have to that um
[Music]
generally i think that people
underestimate the it's cliched you know
freud made it so stupidly cliche that we
throw out the influence of early
childhood interactions but uh
in the same way that we all have accents
that we picked up when we were very very
young that no matter what happens in
life we will not use like
we have accents in what love means to us
we have access accents in what power
means to us and you can you could be
told over and over again but you will
speak with that accent when it comes to
love and power and all these other
things so revisiting it one is very
important and then more specifically to
what you said
uh
what for me and i think every family is
different is to recognize and um have
enough faith in my parents that just
because they don't know the
technological stuff that there isn't
still wisdom there and i think very
early on i said
because it was difficult or frustrating
or i was angry i said you don't know
[ __ ] i'm gonna do it and it served me
well you know my dad wanted me to stay a
consultant i [ __ ] off and started
charisma on command worked you know
there was there was merit to going you
don't know what the hell you're talking
about but
uh
in going back and saying i threw some
baby out with the bathwater and there is
there is wisdom here and the world at
least for me and my family the world is
not a place that i have to discover
entirely on my own
and i have the trust in you that some of
your wisdom can help guide me through it
is what i needed to recognize because i
was too fiercely my own guru my own
independent thing
i think about think about what we were
talking about earlier on that you have
this period of
making yourself
of becoming and then it kind of swings
across into being and then you realize
that maybe some of the things that
served you when you were 21
now your terrorizers when you're 31
and okay now i've got rid of these but
oh [ __ ] like what does this leave me as
now you know this this kind of
vacillation kind of like a pirate ship
at a
theme park right that it just swings
backwards and forwards swings backwards
and forwards and what you hope to try
and do is to get it to sit somewhere
close to where plum would be
and a lot of the time it's just working
out when you're veering off course
um so for instance with your parents you
know you you go through this period
you're totally correct you're totally
correct that you could see
look inevitably everyone who is a
millennial or sort of a gen zed at the
moment is teaching their parents about
technology and you can use that as a
crowbar to not only have power over your
parents but also to kind of throw out
all of the other [ __ ] that they tell you
to do it's like you can't even work the
[ __ ] ipad what are you going to teach
and
learning that again and re-learning okay
[ __ ] i i thought i was the person that
was in control and i was able to help
and be useful and now i need to
de-program that [ __ ] as well and i need
to now reintegrate the thing that i
learned when i was two which is listen
to parents parents often know best
[Laughter]
it's just it's spirals right ever
tighter and tighter circles as josh
weitzgen calls it
yes i i love that uh
yeah it's it's been
i guess when i think about the the ship
it's almost the question is what pushed
the ship to the other side and in many
cases it was like it was pain it was
like i was listening to you guys and it
hurt and so i went never again
and i think that idea of never again
causes people to overcompensate in so
many areas of their life so like they
get rejected by a girl and they go never
again will i feel that pain and then all
of a sudden they train themselves become
these super players who are never in
relationships and never have to suffer
and
somebody said you know one of the most
powerful things you can do is be willing
to experience the thing that you made a
vow to never experience and to say i am
willing to be heartbroken again i'm
willing to have my
mom and dad give me advice that is
heartbreaking again and where that
allows you to come back to
it does allow you get hurt again but it
allows you to land in that middle
instead of just having to stay in this
crazy reactive uh refusal to get hurt by
the way that you got hurt before
aubry told me the story about
the first time
i think he was
21
and he'd just gone away from home
and he went to
vegas on his own
and he went to go and see something like
the cirque du soleil or some other sort
of show apparently was sat in one of the
front rows
watching these women perform these
beautiful
acrobat women perform and apparently he
was there gripping the arms of the chair
and looking at them and saying like
halfway between a mantra and a prayer to
himself i will become the sort of man
that these girls will never say no to in
my this is this is my purpose on this
life and he talks about how most of his
20s and his 30s was um spent
worshiping the divine feminine which is
aubrey speak for um
trying to trust his tale
trying to fill a void inside himself
with lots of women yeah worshiping the
divine feminine um and
now he's married and i asked him about
this question on the show and i was like
look man you know you spent 20 years
building uh 10 years building a business
which just got sold to unilever for a
huge undisclosed amount and not
available
to be honest i think that you're
probably not far off the money like i
need to rediscover what it is to be me
and that's somebody who has now faced
down some of those demons you know he's
had to face down his demons around
insufficiency and around monogamy to get
married so he's leaned into that
discomfort but from that okay so what
about all of the presumptions
and the armor and the protection
strategies that i developed from being
polyamorous from being able to
um
anaesthetize myself from pain within one
relationship with another and be able to
move people and swap them around and the
same with money the fact that
the dopamine spikes as you guys had with
your sales yesterday um if you
got a huge payout for charisma on
command tomorrow
unbelievable dopamine spike but
they're not coming again
now what you're not utilitarian rational
beings it's not about the fact that well
if i got you know 50 million today then
that's me for the this amount of time
and actually the utility is better for
me to have it right now than it would be
for me to have it in the future you
don't think like that in three weeks
time you'd go
come on come on mr reptilian brain is
he's hungry feed me yeah
yeah the i mean with money it seems that
the only thing that yeah people just
want more right and this i think i was
lucky with money to realize this very
early on that
nobody cares about the amount in their
bank they just want it to be more than
it was and if it's even if they have a
50 million bank that is slowly
decreasing that person will likely feel
less
rich than somebody who has 50 000 but
you know is going to have 55 000
in in the next period of time so
i find myself i think
uh i'm younger than aubry but at a
similar
phase of asking you know i was doing a
lot of uh open relationship stuff and
uh i
figuring out what was driving that is i
still haven't gotten to the core of it
but as as i have slowed down and been
now monogamous for a while several
months which feels like a while
congratulations
it's a victory
yeah well i'm i'm becoming aware of the
strategy and there's you know it's
interesting what it does for you it does
a couple things one i never had to worry
about cheating on anyone because i took
that off the table like i can't cheat on
you we're in an open relationship so all
of a sudden my ability self-control
discipline etc it never needs to be
explored number two
uh
i never had to ask myself
uh
why do i want this it was like oh i'm
interested in this i can go and do it
which is a nice feeling to have as
opposed to what is driving this and as i
look into what is driving this it's not
what most people would think in open
relationships which is you know sex and
and all that kind of stuff as i get deep
into it it's like
i feel like i want to be the type of guy
that that type of girl
likes and so it is uh you realize the
sum of and i'm not saying all open
relationships are this and i'm saying
not not that all of my drives are this
but there is an element of it which is
narcissistic
i want you to reflect on me
the you know ways that i would like to
feel about myself
dude
his argument was
i didn't feel like the void was filled
with one woman
but maybe two will do it
[Laughter]
no two hasn't hit it
what about three i need to just tick
tick tick tick tick
yeah and and i don't think that uh
and i i guess what you find is that the
voi that there is no amount and that
doesn't imply is it not 10 yeah i always
thought it was yeah
has he tried does he trade 20.
no that's that's and that's how i see
people with money he's like you know 100
000 didn't do it but maybe a million
would or subscribers i've seen this over
and over again and i guess the question
is how stubborn of a learner am i going
to be i really hope not that stubborn
because i have
been given a lot of the things that i've
aimed for uh jim carrey has a fantastic
quote like i hope you all get every one
of your dreams and hopes met so that you
can realize that none of those are going
to fulfill you and i've been very lucky
to have achieved what i what was a
financial goal or a dating goal or a
charisma
fame level that i wanted to achieve
and
i just hope that my subconscious picks
up that that ain't the game
anymore and
uh it's starting to is what i is what i
can say it's i'm starting to get the
message after a long time and
psychedelics and mdma have been a big
help
i've just thought of something so i have
i've had an insight for a little while
that
there's only so long that imposter
syndrome can stick around
while you disprove it in reality
before you admit to yourself
that this impostor syndrome has nothing
to do with your competence and
everything to do with your thought
patterns and your addiction to the
um imposter syndrome itself
but i think that there's an equivalent
to do with
i will be happy when
yeah there is only so much success and
so many goal stones
milestones that you can reach
and you watch yourself move the goal
posts further away from yourself again
before you admit to yourself that it is
not about the number and it is
everything to do with the mindset that
is leading you toward that interaction
yeah you know and interestingly when i i
speak to people about this and even
myself and they'll say you know i
totally get what you're saying but i
still feel like i need to do it
oftentimes my advice to them is yeah
then you're not done
you have to go get more money and have
to do more stuff because if you're
trying to
do the enlightened thing because that's
what an enlightened person would do
you're still just stuck in that game of
trying to be the best do the righteous
thing it enlight you become enlightened
to the fastest so just bottom out bottom
out on hedonism try not to hurt people
obviously like uh be considerate of
other people's feelings be honest but
keep your eyes open i find is the most
common advice that i'm giving to people
like pay attention to how you feel on
that second date that third date you
know pay attention to the excitement
that you have when you think that you
have a date and how you actually feel
when you're on the date and how you feel
after that date and notice if and when
you feel excitement and fulfillment
throughout that process and what i have
seen as i as i have kept my eyes more
open is that i feel
anxiety when i don't have the triggers
that i think i need excitement
before those triggers are fulfilled and
then as they're being i say i shouldn't
say fulfilled as they're being like you
know
i'll just use a concrete example uh when
i was dating multiple people i would
feel anxiety if it had been a long time
before uh since i had done that i would
feel excitement when
a date was planned and i would feel
fine regular not even amazing on the
date and then sometimes there would come
a point where i was like i don't even
want to be doing this right now like i'd
rather just be home like i was last
night wishing i was here
and so when you realize the crazy
cyclical nature of that uh
that's so i i like i want out is how i
feel people need to [ __ ] keep doing
that they need to understand
how
teleologically wired
humans are so there was a study done
this really really interesting study
done on the most enjoyable part of a
night out and this was quite important
for me i was like i'm going to pay for
the this is after i left uni as well so
i couldn't even access the journal
article so i had to download it and they
had people do self reports right that
self reports for a bunch of different
people like a relatively representative
sample size pretty big study
and they had people do it from the
middle of the afternoon until
12 midday the next day right so
self-report what is your current level
of excitement
peak level of excitement
for pretty much everybody was about 8
p.m when they were getting ready before
they'd gone on the night out they've got
maybe opened the first bottle of wine or
first couple of beers they're getting
ready with them with their bros they're
shouting at each other because
somebody's in the shower they're talking
about where they're going to go and who
they're going to go out with and who's
djing and what the night's going to be
like
that was it we are anticipatory beings
that's what we're here for we're here to
anticipate the thing that arrives and
dissatisfaction is not a bug it is a
feature it is a part of being a human
unsatisfactoriness
is just built in
to human nature because if the
way that you imagined having sex or
eating a meal or chasing down a gorilla
or a cheetah or whatever it is that
you're chasing down you're probably dead
if you chase those two down whatever it
is an antelope
um if it was as satisfying as you
imagined it to be you would never do it
again
it is built into your programming for
everything to just be a bit [ __ ] than
you thought it was
like i hoped it would be ten and it was
like seven and a quarter yeah yeah
because maybe next time like you need to
get it into your head
that that is not because the situation
didn't meet your standards it's because
your brain is wired for you to never be
able to meet those standards it will
always pitch potential reality higher
than actual reality can go and as soon
as you see that code you realize okay
there's this example that i always love
to use
people that are going away on holiday
right you imagine the holiday you plant
it with your yeah oh my gosh
you
think about the hotel that you're going
to stay in you think about the
restaurant you maybe research the
restaurant beforehand and you look at
the menu and you look at the cocktail
list and you think oh god i'm going to
have this amazing trip and you get there
and it's the first night and the sun's
going down and you sat in the in the
restaurant on the exact table the one
that you you spotted on the facebook
page and you sent to your partner and he
said right and you sit down and you're
at the table but then you notice that
there's a bit of sand between your toes
it's sort of a bit irritating and you
got this drink but you've got the
blended one as opposed to the iced one
and maybe it would have been nicer and
there's like the food it's nice but it's
a bit more spicy than you thought and
the sun's kind of
burning my eyes a little bit like
that
is life
there is no situation where that doesn't
happen your ability to be idealistic is
always going to outstrips reality uh
reality's ability to deliver that to you
and as soon as you realize that
that is the shortcut i'm adamant that
that's one of the most important lessons
that everybody needs to learn
i mean and again there's so many
so many angles on that that
that insight
what i'm trying to learn which is the
thing that i cognitively know but like
you described emotionally
yes emotionally don't and i'm still uh
an anticipatory being is that
i want to be a person
more interested in reality than my idea
of reality like because i have seen
through some of the psychedelic stuff
that that is where
the joy is the joy is the sand in your
toes and the crappy [ __ ] and you know
it's it's
this conversation right here and and my
ass on the couch
uh
and
i'm trying and i i haven't figured it
out and perhaps trying is what takes me
away from it you know there's
there's just layers and layers of traps
and these and these sorts of enlighten
me things but that is increasingly where
i'm headed and it's why you know you
asked me a lot of the charisma questions
today and i genuinely had to think back
because
i have learned that making i still think
charisma is a worthy pursuit like i
think finances are a worthy pursuit like
i think dating is a worthy pursuit and
all those sorts of things but where i'm
at is that i no longer
can delude myself into believing that
the more people that like me enjoy my
stories laugh at my jokes is going to
improve my subjective experience of life
at all i just i cannot believe that
given my life experience at this point
i've had too much of it uh and so
personally i've moved away from charisma
and towards
enlightenment whatever you want to call
it spirituality and i'm still just very
very beginner novice in these stages
that said
if you haven't taken the time to
feel like you've locked down your
finances and are satisfied with your or
not satisfied have worked on your dating
life and your social scenario and have a
career that you thought would be you
know really fulfilling i think that you
need to have that first hand experience
of wanting and then being disappointed
to have that lesson really sink in you
can't listen to someone else tell you
that it's not going to be worth it when
you get to the top of mountain you got
to get to the top of the mountain
and go is this it yeah you just have to
do it for yourself in my experience of
what i've seen from friends and family
you need to close that loop there's a
naval quote which i [ __ ] adore and he
says it is far easier to achieve your
material desires than to renounce them
yeah
and that is i love it that is the same
for
pic
status desires
uh notoriety desires sexual desires
whatever everybody who
uh
it was big into pickup artistry and it
was like prolific like just a [ __ ]
weapon an absolute weapon every single
night that we went out there would be
one or two girls that he would go he
would leave a night out at 10 p.m to
take a girl home
have a shower and come back out to get
another girl and take her home and i was
like [ __ ] man like you are
committed
to this thing
like what what is it and he's like yeah
man my future wife she really better
appreciate all of this effort i'm
putting in
you're going to have to you're going to
have to explain to me about how the
hundreds of girls that you're betting is
in tribute to your future unknown wife
he's like well when i'm walking down the
street with my two and a half kids and
my dogs and my wife and i'm pushing the
pram i don't want to look at a brazilian
girl and think i wonder what it's like
to [ __ ] a brazilian girl i want to have
every single one of my sexual quirks
ticked off the list and that's the same
you know it's
a um i i
i do feel like he probably over
delivered on that like that's not
achieving your sexual desires that's
indulging it that's swimming in them um
but
it's the same thing
yeah and i think it's um
in my limited experience i've got to go
in just a minute but it's alright it
uh
yeah i don't know that that's exactly
how it's going to work
i guess my my reaction it's at least for
me it has been um
it's been a journey of
disappointment and frustration and not
one of like got it good i'm ready to
move on to the next thing and i actually
think that there's something important
about that because
uh when i was more in the phase and
still have it in me uh of you know i
wonder i wonder i wonder that doesn't go
away it just it just comes back after
some time different flavors different
hats different faces but you know and
and
time for another conversation but i
still i also think that you know
what we're saying is you know two three
four ten girls isn't gonna do it i'm not
sure that one does either you know and
there is something to be said for the
fact that the monks
uh they renounce sexuality entirely so i
don't want to say that
the answer to all of this because it's
not open relationships is a committed
monogamous relationship i think that
would be uh
a little bit too convenient of logic i'm
open to that possibility but i'm still
exploring that in my life right now and
i don't i do not know the answer funny
story orbs tried celibacy and he lasted
four days
so so maybe it is you know who knows
we'll find out
charlie man uh i'm really really glad
that we connected like we've spoken a
ton this week and i'm very very glad
that we've got each other in our lives
now i think i'm going to come on your
show at some point we'll talk some [ __ ]
and yeah please no i've uh i've had a
great time man chatting with you you are
uh fantastic at listening like truly i
can i can see the way that you engage
with things that are being said i'm i'm
jealous if i was interested in charisma
still that is what i would be working on
well that's a very
very pleasant compliment uh people want
to join charisma university and they
want to check out your channel where
should they go it's charisma on command
on the uh on youtube and in just about
any of our videos at the top of the
description link charisma university you
can google it as well it'll take you to
the page
so man i'm looking forward to speaking
again soon
beautiful take care everybody what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
you